What's my name Jon Snow and why is my surname
snow because you're a bastard from the north
love is the death of Duty
in every man's life there
comes a day when he must choose
I did what I thought was right
and I got murdered for it
kill the boy Jon Snow and let the man be born
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie kit harington
just did a big panel this past weekend talking
about the Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel a little
bit so I'll explain what he said about the actual
plot what they're going to be covering during the
actual series because we have so many questions
about what it's going to cover if you're brand
new to the channel I will be doing videos for it
just like I did for the original Game of Thrones
series just like I do for House of the Dragon be
sure to subscribe to get everything this is
kit harington talking about what's going on
with his character with the events of the sequel
pickup and some of the stuff that they're going
to cover not everything that they're going to
cover but some of it I think if you asked him
he said he would have felt he got off lightly
he you know at the end of the show when we find
him in that cell he's preparing to be beheaded and
he wants to be he's done like the fact he goes to
the wall is the greatest gift to him and also the
great curse he's going to go back up to the place
with all this history and live out his life
thinking about how he killed Downey and live out
his life thinking about eager dying is wrong and
live out his life thinking about how he hung Holly
and live out his life thinking about all
of this trauma and that that's interesting
so I think that the when we leave them at the end
of the show there's always this feeling of like
I think we wanted some kind of little smile things
are okay he's not okay he's not okay but it really
goes down quite deeply to John's internal conflict
which is that he doesn't know who he is he's never
known who he is he knows he at first he identified
with being a bastard but he kind of wanted to
be a Stark and though by the end of the show
there's this Targaryen thing thrown in as well
and we don't really see what is um uh where we
don't get time to see where that sits with him
um but I I think that he doesn't he's never really
known he's been told who he is all through his
life been told who he could be who he should be
he's actually quite far away from knowing who
who and hasn't had time in our show to really
Center upon who John is he doesn't have time to
do that but I think he's Jon Snow he's not John
Stark and he's not John Targaryen he's Jon Snow
so obviously one of the big things that he talks
about during that is that Jon Snow still has no
idea who he is he's been told who he is like
he's been given all these different identities
like this is who you are you're aegon Targaryen
no no you're Jon Snow no you're John Stark and
even at the end of season eight he still has no
idea who he is and he's actually thankful that
he's sent to the wall like he's thankful for the
punishment being banished from the realm in a big
part of what he's going to be doing during the
series is dealing with all the things that he's
had to do kill Daenerys hang Olly like he talks
about killing olly even though it was warranted
definitely wanted to get rid of that guy finally
dealing with egret's death dying in his arms so
that's why he spent so much time talking about
how unwell Jon Snow is like he is not doing okay
there have been a couple news outlets reporting
that the series is supposed to premiere in 2025
I don't know if that's going to wind up sticking
they haven't said anything about when they're
going to start filming the series but it sounds
like they do plan to release this alongside House
of the Dragon episodes which I'm currently in
the middle of doing episodes for like we're
getting ready for House of the Dragon season two
at the convention kit harington actually took a
picture with Patty considine who plays viserys on
house the dragon and if you guys didn't know Jon
Snow and Daenerys both come from renera's line
so he's like his great great great great many
times removed grandfather the big difference is
that house of the Dragon takes place around 200
years earlier in the timeline so it's a prequel
based on the Fire and Blood Targaryen history book
it's about the huge Targaryen Civil War called
the dance of the Dragons when there were tons
of dragons all over Westeros the Jon Snow Game
of Thrones sequel series will take place after
the events of Game of Thrones season 8 after
Jon Snow left to go north of the wall with the
wildlings tormund and ghost so as of right now
them announcing that this Jon Snow sequel is
actually happening with Kit Harington there are
many Game of Thrones spin-off sequels and prequel
shows they're doing but only some of those will
wind up actually turning into episodes that we'll
actually be able to watch on television House of
the Dragon is just the first one that's made it to
actual episodes I will explain all the other shows
that they're working on later in the video and I
know a lot of you are also asking if this affects
Kit Harington playing the black knight from Marvel
inside the turtles movies inside midnight Suns and
any other big crossovers with Avengers 5. I will
address that later in the video too the big thing
I think a lot of people are confused about is that
Dan and Dave are not involved with any Game of
Thrones anything anymore so just because HBO is
doing a sequel doesn't mean that Dan and Dave are
coming back if you did not like what they did with
the show especially towards the last couple of
Seasons don't worry they are not involved with
anything creatively or anything like that one of
the big things that they didn't do from the books
that they could always introduce during the show
One new twist for this character is the idea of
his wolf dreams and being a Warg in the books all
the stark children who still have direwolves that
continue living throughout the series continue
to have wolf dreams which is a version of warging
like they're low-level warging without realizing
it you mostly see this play out through arya's
storyline because she sees visions of nymeria
running around through the woods feeling like
she is nymeria running around through the woods
so when people make jokes about Jon Snow having
a wolf brain that's what they're talking about
like him actually being a work it's just the TV
show never bothered to do that when the original
show ended kit harington and the other main cast
members were kind of iffy about coming back as
their characters because everybody did ask them
are you all coming back for sequels and they're
like well we don't know right after season eight
finished the only one who was like definitely I
will come back was Maisie Williams coming back as
a version of Arya she actually just filmed new
scenes as Arya for Warner Brothers as part of
their big multi versus game that's not meant to be
Canon to A Song of Ice and Fire or Game of Thrones
that's like a completely separate game based on
all the IP that Warner Brothers owns so that's
how you have Arya from Game of Thrones interacting
with DC comic book characters This Game of Thrones
sequel series is a legit Kit Harington coming back
is Jon Snow after the events of season 8 to just
continue the story for at least his character
now they haven't been totally clear on exactly
how much they're going to cover in the show like
is this going to be a Better Call Saul kind of
sequel series even though that's meant to be a
prequel like well just focus on a specific group
of characters and have cameos from people from the
original show or will it be the Breaking Bad movie
where it's more of a one-off miniseries kind of
thing said after the events of the previous be a
story but I did a bunch of videos after the season
8 finale aired for all the deleted scenes in these
alternate endings alternate story lines that they
cut from the finale so I'll link that Below in the
comments and at the end of this so you can learn
about everything that would have happened but the
Game of Thrones sequel series will take place
a little while after Jon Snow went North past
the wall the big thing in the Kingdom right now
is that the wildlings with Jon Snow ghosts have
gone back beyond the wall and even though they've
defeated the night King and therefore killed all
the white walkers the whites that they raised
there's no more need for the actual wall like
it serves no actual purpose anymore originally
it was created 8 000 years ago after the first
long night with the combined help of bran the
Builder who at the time was King of the North he
was the Stark's ancestor he wasn't secretly the
three-eyed Raven version of bran time traveling
with his powers there were all kinds of crazy
theories about that bran the Builder was meant
to be a completely different character that was
an ancestor to these modern day characters who
bran in all of his predecessors with the same name
were named for on the show the big difference is
they condensed the timeline so instead of the
long night being like many thousands of years
ago it was closer to being a thousand years ago
still a long time but not nearly as long but now
in present day three-eyed Raven brand has become
King of the Seven Kingdoms Samwell is his Grand
maester Tyrion is his hand of the king the way
they portrayed things is the realm has been to be
kind of torn on what he did killing Daenerys like
some of the Realms supported Jon Snow and some of
them supported Daenerys but even though Jon Snow
still technically has a claim to the Iron Throne
the great Council that they formed in this finale
scene basically chose bran to be their new king
so the realm supports bran as king but after the
fact after this all plays out he's portrayed as
kind of a controversial figure of Legend amongst
people in the Seven Kingdoms but everybody pretty
much knows that he went north of the wall and
outside of his sister Sansa who's ruling over
Wim to fell in the north really close by no one
else is really worried about Jon Snow that much
like no one's really thinking about what's going
on with the wildlings because they're not even
that large of a group it even brand who you think
would be concerned about his brother Jon Snow is
more like a human turnip like a repository for all
of history so his personality is is more like a AI
he just spits out facts and details about things
from across history anytime you try to talk to
him and Arya has still left Westeros to go to the
Western continent on the other side of the sunset
sea to just explore what's west of Westeros Gendry
is now Lord of the stormlands and if it wasn't
clear obviously Jon Snow is leading the free folk
tormund is kind of like his second in command but
a lot of you are asking who's going to be the main
villain of this show if it's going to be centered
on Jon Snow like what's a central conflict if
they defeated the night King the white walkers
all the whites the undead minions and the animals
they raised well they haven't said that this is
only going to take place up in the north beyond
the wall or if it'll be like a big sprawling
political thriller the way the first show was
but like now in present day because there's no
more night King there are no more spiders big
as hounds there are still a couple groups in
the world of essos that hate the Seven Kingdoms in
general and hate Jon Snow for killing Daenerys so
like he's still hated by a lot of people around
the world and there's further internal conflict
Civil War Brewing between different kingdoms
inside Westeros like just because they beat the
night king beat Cersei everyone went home doesn't
mean that everyone in Westeros and essos now love
each other one of the big themes in George
RR Martin's The Song of Ice and Fire series
is that time plays out into circular nature like
events always have a way of repeating themselves
people always make the same types of mistakes they
haven't confirmed everybody that's coming back for
the show like Sophie Turner would probably come
back because Winterfell is right there next door
south of the wall it would be weird for them to
do this whole ass show about Jon Snow for Five
Seasons and to not show you what's happening at
Winterfell or any of the other Seven Kingdoms so
I believe Better Call Saul style they will try to
feature people from the original cast the biggest
antagonist Left Alive at the end of the main show
were the forces of slaver's bay the iron bank
who really really wants their money back there's
all the forces of the free cities there's what's
left of the doth Rocky the rest of the unsullied
even though gray worm implied at the end of the
main show that he was taking the unsullied or what
remained of them to Noth the island where misandai
originally came from in the Summer Isles in the
Dothraki seemed like they were eventually going
back to essos and there are a lot of other other
kingdoms that they didn't feature during the main
show like other places in essos we didn't go
or didn't see a lot of really good example is
the forces of a shy in the shadowlands that's the
place where Melisandre originally came from right
now the other shows they're still working on are
the nymeria and the 10,000 ships said in the past
there's one specifically about Corlys Velaryon the
sea snake there's a Duncan egg series based on the
books about those characters remember it's sir
Duncan the tall who's the ancestor of Brienne of
Tarth and aegon is really aegon V the future king
of Westeros it's also a prequel series but he is
the younger brother of maester Eamonn there are
also a couple different animated Game of Thrones
series that they're working on we don't know
as much about what's going on with the plot of
those in the whole thing with kit harington
coming back as the Black Knight inside the
Marvel universe is that I believe that's mostly
meant to be Cameo status right now I think for a
little while people were wondering if they would
do a black knight series on Disney plus it sounds
like they're not doing that now and he'll just
be in Future movie Crossovers and that's why he
has so much extra time to do this full Big Game of
Thrones sequel series but everyone posts all your
theories in the comments below who do you want
to be the villain of this new Jon Snow sequel
series I will do more videos for it when we get
more trailers and details because we're getting
ready to film house the Dragon season 2 I'll be
doing bonus videos for that just like I did for
the main Series be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
to learn about the house of the Dragon alternate
ending in deleted scenes and click here to learn
about the Game of Thrones alternate ending
in deleted scenes with Jon Snow and the other
characters thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!